Okay so we have seen that we have to worry about the read after write
dependencies because we actually have to feed the value that the instruction
needs, from a previous instruction. We also have to worry about write after
write dependencies possibly because we don't want, we want the last instruction
in the program order to be the last one to actually. Write the result. And
also anti dependencies we need to worry about them too because, we don't want to
overwrite results before the instructions that need them have had a chance to
use them. So, now we're going to talk about removing false dependencies.
What are false dependencies? Well, we have read after write.
We have write after read. And we can also have a write after a write. These,
are called true dependencies. Because, you actually have to obey them,
that's how the program computes. Some instructions produce values that are then
used by other instructions and so on. So the instructions that use values really
depend on instructions that previously wrote the results. In contrast, these.
Are called, false or name, dependencies. Why?
Well, because there is nothing fundamental about them.
They are dependencies just because you're using the same register for
two different results. So, for example, in a write after write dependency we
have seen that two different instructions would write to the same register and
that creates the write after write dependence. If the second of those two
instructions, were using another register to write this value,
then there would not, be no dependents. We will see an example of this a little
bit later. But the idea is that while true dependencies,
you actually. Have to delay instructions in order to satisfy them,
with the name dependencies you could actually execute instructions earlier.
If only you could take care of, you know kind of multiple values for
the same register as we will see just in case, just in a couple of seconds.